for trends you're now our official eight
news now weather spotter thank you i'm
lying on this one
excuse me i gotta watch this
look outside right now hey i got this
this is gonna be a great sunset shot
outside and go out there get the shot
because with the clouds and the sunsets
you know we get those great sunsets
especially when they turn that little
gray and purplish color and that's what
we're going to get for tonight notice
the camera moving a little bit because
it is a little breezy out there i want
to show you our 8 news now social
dialogue so we asked you how you felt
about these temperatures renee barbour
says she's loving it and then we go to
grace portasio says no need for the ac
look at their nice little icon that she
put there for everybody to see too
barbara omley guys you remember her she
moved to minnesota big news eight news
now watcher she still watches us here
she says same as here in minnesota
that's rare though it's a gorgeous
spring day there and of course a
gorgeous spring day here carol jones
says love it let's hold off the heat as
long as possible carol we're with you
because we know once the heat arrives it
stays and looks like that will be
arriving by the end of the week
currently outside 66 and summerlin
perfect out there 73 right now downtown
in north las vegas 75 for green valley
69 for you roads ranch spanish trail 73
for henderson seven hills anthem you're
all at 70 degrees right now 80 for you
in death valley 65 union springs and
sandy valley 66 double sixes for you
including prom so there's a low situated
to the northwest in the northern
portions of california right now now
this will spin to the east but we talk
about a cold front this will drag
another cold front through the region
tomorrow in fact that's why our winds
will be a gusty tomorrow especially
later on in the day notice those
double-digit wind speeds but let's take
a look at your gusts from 7 am
to 11 pm because i want to make sure
your plan your day and what see what to
expect when's not so bad in the morning
but by the time we get to i'd say early
afternoon and early evening that's when
they will really peak where they could
get up to 40 miles per hour since we'll
have the southwest wind we could see
some dust as well but notice the wind
shift later on in the evening shows us
that cold front passes through and we're
going to stay on the cool side so here's
your 8 to 8 planner tomorrow we do have
that wind like we talked about
temperatures should be right around the
low 70s tomorrow throughout many of our
neighborhoods in fact some of you may
not even reach 70 degrees like we talked
about some other neighborhoods southern
highlands at 69 same for aliante 72
green valley spring valley 69 degrees
we're going to be also nice and cool for
laughlin at 80 65
for you at prim at state line there
eight day forecast looking ahead like we
said some warmth for the weekend it's
going to be hot make sure you put on
that sunblock and next week yep we're
going to stay near the century mark also
with breezy winds back again on sunday
that's your weather update back to you